Episode 15 Reform Movements
Hi I’m John Green.
This is Crash Course U.S. history and today
we finally get to talk about sex.
Also some other things.
Today we’re gonna discuss religious and
moral reform movements in 19th century America,
but I promise there will be some sex.
Mr. Green, Mr. Green.
Is it gonna be about real sex or is it gonna
be able people who are obsessed with not having
sex?
You got me there, Me from the Past.
But how (and whether) we skoodilypoop ends
up saying a lot about America, and also people
in general.
Intro
So, one response to the massive changes brought
about by the shift to an industrialized market
economy was to create utopian communities
where people could separate themselves from
the worst aspects of this brave new world.
The most famous at the time, and arguably
still, were the Shakers, who were famous for
their excellent furniture, so you can’t
say that they really fully withdrew from the
market system.
Still Shaker communities did separate themselves
from the competition that characterized free
markets, especially in terms of the competition
for mates.
They were celibate, and therefore only able
to increase their numbers by recruitment,
which was made a little bit difficult by celibacy.
But they did do a lot of dancing to sublimate
their libidinous urges, they embraced equality
of the sexes, and at their peak they had more
than 6,000 members.
Today, they are still one of the most successful
utopian communities to have emerged in the
19th century.
They have three members.
Much more successful in the long run were
the Latter Day Saints, also called Mormons,
although at the time their ideas were so far
out of the mainstream that they were persecuted
and chased from New York all the way to Utah.
In addition to the Bible, The LDS Church holds
the Book of Mormon as a holy scripture, which
tells of the resurrected Jesus’s visits
to the Americas.
And while it was subject to widespread persecution,
and even some massacres, the LDS Church continued
to grow, and in fact continues to today.
So, while some of these communities were based
in religion, others were more worldly attempts
to create new models of society, like Brook
Farm.
Founded in 1841 by a group of transcendentalists,
is a dependent clause that always ends in
failure, Brook Farm tried to show that manual
labor and intellectual engagement could be
successfully mixed.
This community drew on the ideas of the French
socialist Charles Fourier, who as you may
recall from Crash Course World History believed—no
joke—that socialism would eventually turn
the seas to lemonade.
And much like Fourier’s planned communities,
Brook Farm did not work out, largely because—and
I can say this with some authority—writers
do not enjoy farming.
Nathaniel Hawthorne, for instance, complained
about having to shovel horse manure.
But if he’d only kept shoveling horse manure,
he might not have shoveled The Blithedale
Romances onto an unsuspecting reading public.
I’m sorry, Nathaniel Hawthorne.
I do like The Scarlet Letter, but I feel like
the only reason you’re read is because you
were, like, the only author in pre-Civil War
America.
So either we have to pretend that America
began with Huck Finn’s journey on the Mississippi
or else we’re stuck with you.
It was just, like, you, Thomas Paine, Mary
Rowlandson, a bunch of printed sermons, and
James Fenimore Pooper.
Anyway, the most utopian of the utopian communities
were set up at Utopia, Ohio and Modern Times,
New York by Josiah Warren.
Everything here was supposed to be totally
unregulated and voluntary including marriage,
which, as you can imagine worked out brilliantly.
But, without any laws to regulate behavior,
Warren’s communities were individualism
on steroids, so they collapsed spectacularly
and quickly.
But these utopian communities were relatively
rare; many more 19th century Americans participated
in efforts to reform society rather than just
withdraw from it.
And behind most of those reform movements
was religion, particularly a religious revival
called the 2nd Great Awakening.
This series of revival meetings reached their
height in the 1820s and 1830s with Charles
Grandison Finney’s giant camp meetings in
New York.
And in a way the 2nd Great Awakening made
America a religious nation.
The number of Christian ministers in the United
States went from 2,000 in the 1770s to 40,000
by 1845.
And western New York was the center of this
revivalism.
That’s where Joseph Smith had his revelations.
It’s also where John Humphrey Noyes founded
his Oneida Community, in which postmenopausal
women introduced teenage boys to sex, and
which eventually ceased being a religious
community and evolved into—wait for it—one
of the world’s largest silverware companies.
That’s right, every time you take a bite
of food with Oneida cutlery, you’re celebrating
free love and May-December relationships.
Well, more like February-December relationships.
(Libertage: Turning Free Love into Fancy Forks)
So, yes, religious fervor burned so hot in
upstate New York that it became known as the
“burned-over district,” and New York remains
the heartland of conservative Christianity
to this day.
Or not.
The Awakening stressed individual choice in
salvation and a personal relationship with
Jesus Christ, and it was deeply influenced
by the market revolution.
So, like, while many preachers criticized
the selfish individualism inherent in free
market competition, there was sort of a market
for new religions and preachers, who would
travel the country drumming up business.
Awakening ministers also preached the values
of sobriety, industry and self-discipline,
which had become the essence of both the market
economy and the impulse for reform.
There are three points I want to make about
the religious nature of all these 19th century
reform movements.
First, it was overwhelmingly Protestant.
Like, all these “new” religions were protestant
denominations, which meant that they wouldn’t
have a lot of appeal to immigrants from Ireland
and Germany who started to pour into the United
States in the middle of the 19th century because
A. those people were mostly Catholic, and
B. reasons we’ll get to momentarily.
Secondly, many of these reformers believed
in perfectionism, the idea that individuals
and society were capable of unlimited improvement.
And third, many of the reform movements were
based ultimately on a different view of freedom
than we might be used to.
And this is really important to understand,
for 19th century reformers, freedom was the
opposite of being able to do whatever you
wanted, which they associated with the word
license.
They believed that true freedom was like an
internal phenomenon that came from self-discipline
and the practice of self control.
Essentially, instead of being free to drink
booze, you would be free from the temptation
to drink booze.
According to Philip Schaff, a minister who
came to Pennsylvania in the 1840s, “true
national freedom, in the American view [is]
anything but an absence of restraint … [It]
rests upon a moral groundwork, upon the virtue
of self possession and self control in individual
citizens.”
Members of the fastest growing Protestant
denominations like Methodists and Baptists
were taught that it wasn’t enough to avoid
sin themselves; they also needed to perfect
their communities.
And that leads us to America’s great national
nightmare, temperance.
Now you’re not going to see me advocate
for prohibition of alcohol, but to be fair,
Americans in the first half of the 19th century
were uncommonly drunk.
In fact, in 1830, per capita liquor consumption
was 7 gallons per year, more than double what
it is now.
And that doesn’t even count wine, beer,
hard cider, zima, pruno.
By the way, some people like to have home
breweries or whatever, but at our office,
Stan’s been making pruno under the couch.
The growing feeling among reformers that we
should limit or even ban alcohol appealed
to those protestant ideas of restraint and
perfecting the social order.
And that’s also precisely why it was so
controversial, especially among Catholic immigrants,
who A. came largely from Germany and Ireland,
two nations not known for their opposition
to strong drink,
and B. were Catholic and the Catholic church’s
morality didn’t view alcohol or dancing
as inherently sinful the way that so many
Protestant denominations did.
And then we have the widespread construction
of asylums and other homes for outcasts.
Anyone who’s ever done a bit of urban exploring
knows that these places were built by the
hundreds in the 19th century—jails, poorhouses,
asylums for the mentally ill—and while they
might not seem like places of freedom, to
reformers they were.
Remember, freedom was all about not having
the choice to sin so you could be free of
sin.
Bear in mind, of course, that the crusading
reformers who built these places usually chose
not to live in them.
And speaking of places you’re forced to
go regardless of whether you want to, the
mid 19th century saw the growth of compulsory
state-funded education in the United States.
These new schools were called common schools,
and education reformers like Horace Mann hoped
that they would give poor students the moral
character and body of knowledge to compete
with upper-class kids.
And that worked out great.
Just look at where we are on the equality
of opportunity index.
Now, this may seem like an obvious win for
all involved, but many parents opposed common
schools because they didn’t want their kids
getting moral instruction from the government.
That said, by 1860, all northern states had
established public schools.
But they were far less common in the South,
where the planter class was afraid of education
falling into the wrong hands, like for instance,
those of poor whites and especially slaves.
Which brings us to abolition.
Let’s go to the Thought Bubble.
Abolitionism was the biggest reform movement
in the first half of the 19th century, probably
because—sorry alcohol and fast dancing—slavery
was the worst.
In the 17th and 18th centuries, the only challengers
to slavery were slaves themselves, free blacks,
and Quakers.
But in the early 19th century, colonizationists
began to gain ground.
Their idea was to ship all former slaves back
to Africa, and the American Colonization Society
became popular and wealthy enough to establish
Liberia as an independent homeland for former
slaves.
While the idea was impractical, and racist,
it appealed to politicians like Andrew Jackson
and Henry Clay.
And some black people, who figured that America’s
racism would never allow them to be treated
as equals, did choose to emigrate to Liberia.
But most free blacks opposed the idea; in
fact in 1817, 3,000 of them assembled in Philadelphia
and declared that black people were entitled
to the same freedom as whites.
By 1830, advocates for the end of slavery
became more and more radical, like William
Lloyd Garrison, whose magazine The Liberator
was first published in 1831.
Known for being “as harsh as truth and as
uncompromising as justice,” Garrison once
burned the Constitution, declaring it was
a pact with the devil.
Radical abolitionism became a movement largely
because it used the same mix of pamplheteering
and charismatic speechifying that people saw
in the preachers of the Second Great Awakening,
which in turn brought religion and abolition
together in the North, preaching a simple
message: Slavery was a sin.
By 1843, 100,000 Northerners were aligned
with the American Anti-Slavery Society.
What made the radical abolitionists so radical
was their inclusive vision of freedom.
It wasn’t just about ending slavery but
about equality—the extension of full citizens’
rights to all people, regardless of race.
By the way, it was abolitionists who re-christened
the Old State House Bell in Philadelphia the
“Liberty Bell.”
Why does all this awesome stuff happen in
Philadelphia?
Thanks, Thought Bubble.
So, needless to say, not all Americans were
quite so thrilled about abolitionism, which
is why slavery remained unabolished.
Often, resistance to abolitionism was violent—like,
in 1838, a mob in Philadelphia burned down
Pennsylvania Hall because people were using
it to hold abolitionist meetings.
And you were doing so well, Philadelphia!
A year later, a mob in Alton, Illinois murdered
antislavery editor Elijah P. Lovejoy when
he was defending his printing press.
This was the fifth time, by the way, that
a mob had destroyed one of his newspapers.
Even Congress got in on the “let’s suppress
free speech and the press” act by adopting
the gag rule in 1836.
The gag rule prohibited members of congress
from even reading aloud or discussing calls
for the emancipation of slaves.
Seriously.
And you thought the filibuster was dysfunctional.
The best known abolitionist was Frederick
Douglass, a former slave whose life story
was well known because he wrote the brilliant
Narrative of the Life of Frederick Douglass,
An American Slave.
But he wasn’t the only former slave to write
about the evils of slavery: Josiah Henderson’s
autobiography was probably the basis for the
most famous anti-slavery novel ever, Uncle
Tom’s Cabin.
Uncle Tom’s Cabin sold more than a million
copies between 1851 and 1854.
And despite the unreadable, heavy-handed prose
drenched in sentimentality, the book is a
great reminder that bad novels can also change
the world, which is why it was so widely banned
in the South.
But while based on a black man’s story,
Uncle Tom’s Cabin was written by a white
woman, which shows us that black abolitionists
were battling not just slavery but near ubiquitous
racism.
Like Pat Boone rerecording Little Richard
to make it safe for the white kids at the
sockhop.
They had to fight the pseudoscience arguing
that black people were physically inferior
to white people or just born to servitude,
and they had to counter the common conception—still
common, I’m afraid—that there was no such
thing as African civilization.
Oh, it’s time for the mystery document?
The rules here are simple.
If I guess the author of the mystery document,
I do not get shocked.
Let’s see what we got today.
“Beloved brethren – here let me tell you,
and believe it, that he lord our God, as true
as he sits on his throne in heaven, and as
true as our Savior died to redeem the world,
will give you a Hannibal, and when the Lord
shall have raised him up, and given him to
you for your possession, O my suffering brethren!
remember the divisions and consequent sufferings
of Carthage and of Haiti … But what need
have I to refer to antiquity, when Haiti,
the glory of the blacks and terror of tyrants,
is enough to convince the most avaricious
and stupid of wretches?”
Alright Stan, this is going to take some serious
critical thinking skills so let’s break
this down.
So the author’s clearly African American,
and an admirer of the Haitian Revolution,
which means this was written after 1800.
Plus, he references Hannibal, who Crash Course
World History fans will remember almost conquered
the Romans using freaking elephants!
And Hannibal was from Carthage which, I don’t
need to tell you, is in Africa.
He also warns that Haiti is the terror of
tyrants, referencing the widespread massacring
of white people after the revolution.
Okay that’s what we know.
And now we shall make our guess.
Henry Highland Garnett?
UGH I HATE MYSELF.
It’s David Walker?
I’m not gonna lie to you, Stan, I don’t
even know who that is, so I probably deserve
this.
AH!
That’s how you learn, fellow students.
It’s not about positive reinforcement.
It’s about shocking yourself when you screw
up.
I got a 3 on the AP American History test,
so I should know.
So black abolitionists like Frederick Douglass,
Henry Highland Garnett and apparently David
Walker were the most eloquent spokesmen for
the ideal of equal citizenship in the United
States for black and white people.
In his 1852 Independence Day Address.
By the way, international viewers, our Independence
Day is July 4th, so he gave this speech on
July 4th.
Frederick Douglass said:
“Would you argue with me that man is entitled
to liberty?
That he is the rightful owner of his own body?
You have already declared it.
Must I argue the wrongfulness of slavery?
… There is not a man beneath the canopy
of heaven that does not know that slavery
is wrong for him.”
And in the end, the sophistication and elegance
of the black abolitionists’ arguments became
one of the strongest arguments for abolition.
If black people were better off enslaved,
and inherently inferior, how could anyone
account for a man like Frederick Douglass?
Abolitionism—at least until after the Civil
War—pushed all other reform movements to
the edges.
But I just want to note here at the end that
it’s no coincidence that so many abolitionist
voices, like Harriet Beecher Stowe for instance,
were female.
And their work toward a more just social order
for others transformed the way that American
women imagined themselves as well, which is
what we’ll be discussing next week.
I’ll see you then.
Thanks for watching.
Crash Course is produced and directed by Stan
Muller.
Our script supervisor is Meredith Danko.
The associate producer is Danica Johnson.
The show is written by my high school history
teacher Raoul Meyer and myself.
And our graphics team is Thought Café.
If you have questions about today’s video,
you can ask them in comments where they’ll
be answered by our team of historians.
You can also suggest captions for the libertage.
Thanks for watching Crash Course and as we
say in my hometown, don’t forget to be awesome.
Gonna hit the globe!